Брудні, голодні, на узбіччі суспільства. Якщо людина опинилася на вулиці,
здається, шлях до нормального життя для неї назавжди закритий.
Та за десять кілометрів від Львова, у містечку Винники, вважають інакше.
У цьому будинку оселилася Спільнота взаємодопомоги "Емаус-Оселя".
Ця громадська неприбуткова організація одна з перших в Україні почала опікуватись людьми у скруті.
За головну тут Наталка Мисула.  Хоча сама цей статус заперечує:
тут і колишні безпритульні, і працівники спільноти за графіком виконують усю роботу.
Сьогодні, наприклад, Наталчина черга роздавати обіди для безхатченків у Львові.
Та поки є час до виїзду, жінка показує, як влаштоване життя в спільноті.
ось так виглядають кімнати. Проживають 22 особи.
В зимовий сезон більше, а коли і по три особи в кімнаті.
У дві тисячі третьому році на цьому місці була стара хатина, де жили монахині, розповідає Наталка.
Викупити приміщення і землю допоміг міжнародний рух "Емаус",
який підтримує людей з особливими потребами в різних країнах світу.
Коли збудували притулок і перші безхатченки оселилися в Винниках, місцеві жителі не були їм раді.
Ми пережили гучні сесії Винниківської влади зі скандалами з тим, що вони проти.
Що їм це не потрібно. Що будуть красти по селу.
Але ми це пережили владнали і зараз в нормальних відносинах з сусідами і всі нас знають.
Місія української "Емаус-Оселі"  -  не лише прихистити безхатченків,
але й за допомогою праці та спільного господарства повернути людям спрагу до життя.
Це і праця і можливість відчути себе знову гідною людиною. І мати роль в суспільстві.
Для цього організували майстерню з ремонту меблів. Замовники різні: від місцевих мешканців,
до 5-тизіркових готелів Львівщини.  Поруч крамничка, де члени спільноти продають результати своєї праці.
А ці двері відчинені для усіх безпритульних, де можна помитися, попрати одяг або отримати новий.
"Оселя" має на меті стати самоокупною. Та це не так просто.
Цьогоріч вдалося самостійно покрити половину усіх витрат, із рештою допомогли благодійників з усьогo світу.
Від місцевої влади - дещо більше одного відсотка від усіх пожертв, здебільшого на засоби гігієни та медикаменти.
Місто нас підтримує, вони визнають нашу діяльність,
але якихось надзвичайних речей поки не відбувається. Можливо з якимось часом.
Час поспішати до Львова, роздавати обід. Водій сьогодні затримався.
Йому довелось терміново відвезти одного з жителів спільноти в лікарню.
На жаль зірвався один з наших мешканців. Випив. Пішов у відпустку і випив.
Дорогою, Наталя розповідає про особливості роботи в "Оселі".
Емоційно це є дуже складно, бо ти стикаєшся  з дуже важкими життєвими історіями
і ти співпереживаєш в будь-якому випадку. Не можна просто абстрагуватись і не думати про всі ці історії.
До влади  Наталка не прагне. Каже, там і ресурс обмежений, і можливостей не так багато, як здається.
Тож навряд чи могла б зробити для безпритульних більше.
Жінка щаслива почуватися частиною всесвітньої спільноти "Емаус".
Її колеги в інших країнах десятиліттями рятують людей з особливими потребами.
Це надихає Наталю не складати руки.